>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Music ]
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
We're talking with Brett Dean,
composer, violaist, and conductor.
You are just the most perfect person
to tell us about all things viola,
but anyway it's very exciting
for us to present you here
at the Library of Congress.
As both a composer and a performer,
your new work, Rooms of Elsinore,
in a co-commission with
the Library of Congress
and the Santa Fe Chamber
Music Festival.
We're looking forward to hearing the
premiere and we're also delighted
that you're going to be playing
on our viola collection item.
So, tell us a little bit
about how did that happen.
How did you become a violaist, a
composer, a composer for the viola?
>> Brett Dean: Well, I started
on violin, as most kids do,
and changed to viola when
I was in secondary school.
When I was sort of big enough
to hold the viola, as it were.
And my first teacher in--
this is back in Brisbane--
was herself a viola player
and so recognized not only
something physical about, you know,
how it might suit me, but also--
it's a very different
temperament too.
Viola attracts a different
kind of musician.
I mean we're often
the butt of jokes.
We won't go there.
I mean I quite like the older
jokes, to be honest with you.
I think it's nice to be able to--
nice to be able to laugh at
oneself a little, but I think also,
you know, it's an instrument
that because it's an inner voice,
it's like being in the engine room.
And I think that's perhaps why
there are an unusually high number
of viola-playing composers or
composers who also played the viola.
For me personally, when I
spent 15 wonderful years
in the Berlin Philharmonic
Orchestra,
it was just the greatest
place to sit
and watch all that was happening.
And I hadn't really started
out then as a composer.
Composition came quite late in
the day, really, but as I got more
into it, I was just sort of, you
know, each day at work was a chance
to sit and observe and learn from
all these great players around me.
And with a viola sectional, so
in Berlin, sitting on the outside
of the string section opposite the
first violins, you had this sort
of sweeping gaze across
the orchestra
and it was incredibly invigorating
and inspiring, you know,
to sort of go along to work and
learn from what I saw around me.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: Right.
So, you started out on
violin and went to viola.
What do you think was the reason
for that and was it a sound?
>> Brett Dean: Well,
I mean, as I said,
my teacher could recognize something
about my personality that she felt
as a viola player herself would suit
a viola and I have to say, you know,
I was enjoying playing the violin,
but I think she could recognize
that, you know, there was--
I got to a certain level and this
was the kind of change I needed.
Early into secondary school, a great
opportunity above all to play lots
of chamber music--
because you're always
in high demand as a viola player.
Even then and in-- even
in far-away Brisbane.
You know? Viola players
weren't that many of them
and so there was always lots to do.
Even, you know, in school age and
so I relished that opportunity
and really just went for it.
And, yes, there was something about
the distinctive sound of the viola
that I really got into then.
It wasn't, you know,
the shrill high violin.
I love the cello as well.
I mean I love all the
string instruments,
but there's something quite
distinctive and unusual
about the viola, temperament
but also color of voice
that really appealed to me.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Then, as a composer,
are you finding that's informing the
viola works-- that special sound,
like, instead of writing
for a violin
in the piece that we'll be hearing?
>> Brett Dean: Sure.
I mean having said that, a lot
of it's quite high and I love,
actually, the high
register of the viola.
I've written quite a bit for
viola and some violaists say well,
why don't you just write it for a
violin, it's in violin register,
but it's a completely
different sound
to a violin in the same register.
And I mean I love playing on
the C string as well and going
down into the depths of the
instrument, but I do like, you know,
finding the extremities
of any instrument, really.
But also, you know, in this case,
the extremities of the viola.
To sort of take it out
of its comfort zone, too.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
So, in the piece,
in the commissioned piece, is
there anything you're finding
with this instrument that
you can do or you can't do?
Like, tell me how that sort of--
>> Brett Dean: Well, I mean we only
got to know each other yesterday
and so, you know, it's
still a getting to know you,
getting to know all
about you situation.
And, to be honest, at first,
I was toying with the idea
of playing the Schumann only
on this wonderful instrument
and then playing my
piece on my own viola.
But, apart from the fact
that they're quite different,
it was just so wonderful.
Right from the outset I felt this
clarity and this beauty of sound.
You know, I really
like my own instrument.
It's a modern German viola
made for me about 20 years ago
by at the time a very young maker
called Kevin Gentges in Berlin.
But, of course, this sort
of teaches me something else
about the instrument, its
potential, its characteristics,
and about my own playing that I'm
just really enjoying the experience.
It's something so different.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
This viola has been on loan
to the Library of Congress
since 1977.
It was built in 1690, a part of a
commission for the Medici family.
So, we've been fortunate.
We have two here at the
Library of Congress,
but this one in particular, I'm
curious to hear a little bit more
about your thoughts in
the piece and why you--
what the sounds are
that you're thinking
and if you want to
at all demonstrate.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah.
Well, I mean it's quite an
early instrument then, 1690.
I mean the other one
is later, is it?
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
The other one is 1727.
>> Brett Dean: Right.
Yeah.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Quite a lot later.
>> Brett Dean: The Golden Age.
So, yeah, I'd really love to compare
sometime, but look, it's fascinating
in that although it's so
different to my own instrument,
it has a similar measurement,
overall length,
so that has made it a
little easier to sort
of negotiate right from the start.
It's-- the thing about
violas generally is
that there's no standard
size, of course.
It's not like violins and celli
that more or less have a kind
of accepted standard size.
Violas differ hugely.
You know, I wonder also whether
this may have been changed
in size over the years.
It was certainly not uncommon for
violas to be huge and cumbersome
and then over the years
have been reduced in size
to make them more playable.
Having said that, it looks,
you know, it looks so perfect
in its dimensions, it's quite
possible that it belonged
to the slightly smaller
category of violas where--
at a time where their
differences were massive.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
And, also, why it left the--
it was part of a quintet
that was commissioned
and it was sold off in 1803.
Went to England and then
to France, back to England,
and then came to America
in about 1925.
>> Brett Dean: A quintet
of string instruments?
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Of Stradivari instruments.
>> Brett Dean: So, was that two
violins, two violas, and a cello?
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: Right.
>> Brett Dean: And
I'm pretty sure then
that this perhaps was
the smaller of--
the other one was going
to be much bigger.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: Right.
So, I don't know why it was
broken up and why it's here,
but we're fortunate to have it
on loan to us and available.
>> Brett Dean: Well, I mean
there's one thing that--
there's this moment-- there's
this moment that keeps recurring
as a kind of motto in
my piece, which is this.
[ Music ]
This sort of broken
arpeggio I think.
And I must say, with this
instrument, it sits kind of nicely
on the hand, which can--
with a really large viola,
you'd have to have
a very nice big hand
to manage it going
up to a high C sharp.
So, you know, it's working
out nicely for me thus far.
It takes a little bit of getting
used to, in this instance,
quite a different sort
of C string sound.
And I notice that--
[ Music ]
Which I sometimes admit
I have to do, you know,
on my modern instrument to
really get it to give everything,
that doesn't work with
an instrument like this.
It needs caressing
in a different way.
Partly also because it has
so much clarity anyway.
[ Music ]
You know, it has this sort of--
it speaks very immediately.
And, yeah, I mean I'm finding it
really thoroughly fascinating.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: So--
and you're liking the C string?
>> Brett Dean: Yeah.
I mean the C string takes a little
bit of getting used to and, I mean,
on my instrument-- this is a
moment from a Hindemith concerto.
[ Music ]
It's a moment that, you know,
on my own instrument, I
really kind of dig in.
Here, I feel with this
instrument it--
[ Music ]
It sort of responds better if
you just give it a bit more space
and bow transport and
don't hit it as hard.
And, you know, 24 hours into our
relationship, I'm still getting
to know how to bring out
the best in this instrument.
And, you know, players will spend
a lifetime with an instrument
of this quality and still not get
to know all that it can offer.
So, it's all too--
it's all too brief.
I want one.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Well, fortunately you'll be here
for a few more days with it.
I mean can you really tell the
differences in your instrument,
this one, and then how
you're going to apply that to
which piece you're picking
and what you're composing for?
I mean--
>> Brett Dean: Well, of course,
as far as the composition itself
is concerned, I was sort of working
on my own instrument and wasn't
really thinking about playing it
on something as glorious as this and
at the time also I wasn't even aware
of the Strad being part
of the deal, as it were.
But--
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
But you had played on another--
>> Brett Dean: I have
played on a Stradivarius.
The so-called Gustav Mahler viola,
which was also a wonderful
experience.
That's quite some time ago,
probably almost 20 years ago,
with a group of string players
from the Berlin Philharmonic
and everyone except
the double bass player
because there isn't a
Stradivarius double bass,
but everyone was playing
Strads on a tour of Japan and,
you know, incredible sound.
They were, I guess, also in
different states of repair
and care and, you know, to
maintain an instrument like this is,
you know, as you know,
it's a full-time thing.
You know? It needs constant
attention and, you know,
care and so with so many instruments
that was sometimes a little
varied in response and so on.
But, nevertheless, as a general
ensemble sound, to have just nothing
but Strads on the stage
was quite something.
One of the-- one of the
frustrations, I guess--
and this is-- this is an aspect
of the profession in many ways,
but particularly in an instance
like this, playing on an instrument
like this for such a short time, I'd
really love to be cloned and be able
to go out and have a
listen while I'm playing.
You know? Because that would
also just tell me so much
in such a quick time to really
know how it's-- how it projects.
But it seems to uncannily
sort of have--
well, I mean that's the great
thing about these instruments.
They really do project in a
way that you can't always tell
under the ear or, you know,
right on top of the instrument.
And I think that's, you know, one
of the things that really, you know,
shows the true quality of an
instrument is its ability to carry.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: So,
tell me about your inspiration
for the piece and the sound of
the viola and how that works.
I mean what inspires
you, in general?
Does sound inspire you?
>> Brett Dean: Oh, absolutely.
I mean sound itself is
the stuff of it, really.
I mean, for a painter, it's color.
I use that similarity
quite deliberately
because my wife's a painter and
so we talk about this quite a lot.
And yet there are sort
of things that are very--
that are common to both
of our undertakings,
namely, you know, color itself.
Sound has color.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: And
some musicians see in color.
>> Brett Dean: Absolutely.
Yeah. Well, I'm not synesthetic,
but nevertheless, I, you know,
I can sort of see where
that comes from.
I mean composition itself, the way
a painting is structured, you know,
I've learned so much from being with
a creative artist for so many years.
In this particular instance, the
piece that we're doing on Saturday
and is being commissioned
by the library is part
of an ongoing fascination and
immersion into Shakespeare's Hamlet,
which is culminating in just
a few weeks in the UK in June
with the premiere of a Hamlet opera
that I've written for Glyndebourne.
And so, in even taking
on this commission,
I said right from the start
that I'd love to do this,
but I have to say I'm going to be
so deeply into Hamlet that is it OK
if it's kind of based on the
same-- the same material and so on.
Which, you know, thankfully it
was fine with the commissioners
and with yourselves at the library
and with the Santa Fe
Chamber Music Festival.
And indeed, it's kind of gone
its-- very much its own direction,
nevertheless using, you
know, tunes from the score.
In this instance, what I've done
is also tried to conjure something
of the spaces in which
the drama unfolds.
So, the piece is called
Rooms of Elsinore.
While I was working on
the opera for, you know,
best part of a three-year
period, I had on my-- on my-- in--
on the walls of my studio, I had
a whole series of photos taken
at so-called Elsinore or
the Kronborg, north of--
yeah, North of Copenhagen
in Denmark.
And not that-- certainly, I'm pretty
certain even though I haven't seen
all of the costumes or anything,
but it's not necessarily
a period costume drama
that is being presented.
The director is Neil Armfield,
wonderful Australian
theatre director.
Nevertheless, it was fascinating
having done a tour of the castle
to have these photos particularly
placed chronologically as far
as the unfolding of the drama
was concerned for myself
and for my librettist
Mathew Jocelyn.
And also I had this map of-- taken
from the sort of tourist guide.
And so, what I've tried to do
is make a kind of guided tour
of the space and we enter
through the dark gate
into the four-gate courtyard, then
to the platform where, first of all,
Horatio and Marcellus and later
Hamlet himself sees the ghost
of the old King Hamlet.
Through to the king's chamber and
eventually to the queen's chamber,
out through the chapel, and closing
with a sort of bird's eye view taken
from the so-called
trumpeter's tower.
So, in using moments
from the actual opera,
it nevertheless has its
own dramaturgy, really.
And we're also just
getting to know it.
Juho and I just started
work on it today.
Juho Pohjonen, a wonderful
Finnish pianist.
So, it's, you know, it's a
fascinating bit of discovery for us.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: And then
to add another instrument into it.
>> Brett Dean: And then a sort of
whole different dimension as well.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Is that daunting?
>> Brett Dean: Look, I must say I
was a little concerned because--
I mean pianists have to-- they
live their lives doing that and,
as Juho said earlier, and of course
if it's not a good instrument,
then you've got an excuse.
I don't have any excuses here,
but getting to know a different
instrument for a string player,
as I said, you know, we create real
relationships with the instruments
that we have under our chins
and just to sort of get
to know a new instrument and three
days later play a concert on it,
it's something that, you
know, is-- can be daunting.
I'm thrilled with how
we're getting on so far.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: So, it's
been-- it's not been that difficult.
It's been an easy introduction.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah and also
I'm glad that I came, you know,
a day earlier than
originally planned
so that we had a bit of,
you know, time together.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: Right.
I mean we're lucky
here at the library
that we do have these
instruments here.
We have this amazing concert hall.
We have the music here and
we have composers, like you,
we commission music
and we keep the music.
It is-- it is wonderful.
We do have to preserve the
instrument too, though,
so sometimes, you know,
balancing it out and--
>> Brett Dean: Yeah, I can imagine.
But it's so great that
they get played.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bradford: Right.
>> Brett Dean: That is
part of their health--
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bradford: And
that's what the first bequest
in 1935 with the five Stradivari
instruments was to be played.
To be heard by the public.
And that's what we do and the Tuscan
Corporation, which has graciously,
generously lent us this since 1977--
at first for the Julliard Quartet
who was on residence
here for a long time.
They also, you know, wants
to be played and to be heard
and so we endeavor to do
that as much as possible.
I'm wondering, in the
world of composition
and viola playering [phonetic]--
playing, are there more pieces
being written currently?
Are there more violaists?
>> Brett Dean: Oh, look, I think the
wonderful thing about the viola--
I mean in the same way that there
is no sort of standard size,
there's also no standard repertoire.
You know, we don't have dozens of
sonatas by Mozart or Beethoven.
We don't have concertos by
Brahms and Sibelius and so on.
And so, in many ways, the repertoire
is still coming into fruition.
It's so wonderful to know
that Hindemith played
on the stage of the Coolidge Hall.
One of my great heroes,
particularly in that first time
where I was changing to viola
and then following that sort
of getting more and
more into composition.
He was certainly, you
know, one of my heroes.
And, you know, the great work
that he did for the instrument.
So, I mean it is still--
it's still coming into focus,
but I think because of that
there is this fascination with it
because it's kind of
unfinished business in some ways
and no one quite knows
where that can lead to.
So, I mean I'm thrilled also to be
doing my bit and with this piece
for viola, it-- alongside
two pieces for solo viola
or viola concerto trio
with clarinet and piano.
Yeah, I mean it's also been-- there
have been very important key works
for myself on my path as a composer.
Largely because also they're pieces
that I've been able to play a lot,
so it's sort of been part of
embedding that relationship
of what it means to be
a performing composer
and playing your own
works regularly.
I think that's been an
incredibly important thing for me.
Also, to have calling
cards of pieces
that you can take around the place.
A bit like a traveling salesman.
And, I mean, the viola concerto
in particular has just been
a fantastic way to make music
with orchestras all around the
world and different conductors
and the solo pieces as well have
been, you know, really important
to take to festivals and be able
to say this is really who I am.
You know? This is the instrument I
play and this is what I want to say
with that instrument and they're
pieces that have been particularly--
for that reason, particularly
important and dear to me.
So, I hope that this new piece
gets a few outings as well,
because so far it's-- I mean
it's challenging to play.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: Is it
challenging to write for a viola?
>> Brett Dean: It-- look, it
has its challenges for sure.
The viola concerto has been-- is
a particularly challenging genre
because in the way that it sits,
you know, sort of more in the middle
of the overall register of an
orchestra, it's difficult to sort
of make space for it, but make
space for it you need to do
so that it can be heard in
a setting with orchestra,
and so that's been part of
the learning process too.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
You know,
there aren't many extant
Stradivari violas.
>> Brett Dean: No.
While we're talking about
that, how many are really?
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Maybe 10.
Maybe, you know, give or take.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah.
And I mean the ratio between
violas and violins was something--
eight violins to every
viola or something.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: Right.
I think there's extant
maybe over 600 violins.
>> Brett Dean: Oh, really?
As many as that?
Right. Yeah.
I mean the repertoire for the viola,
yeah, I mean it's a niche part
of the repertoire, but I think
because, as I was saying earlier,
it's still kind of coming into
fruition, it does fascinate people.
Certainly, you know, the
Viola Fraternity as a group
of players themselves are I think
by definition just much
more open to new music.
We have to be.
You know? It would be
silly not to be open to it
because that's the future
of the instrument too.
You know, as I say, we don't have
the great cannon of solo repertoire
to rest on and fall back on
in the same way as the cello
and in particular the violin.
So, you know, I think it-- that is
also something of the difference
in attitude and personality
of violaists.
You know? We're much more keen
to explore new repertoire.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
We did commission a piece
for viola a couple of years ago too.
Actually, for this one, do you mind?
I don't know if you
want to consider that.
What about composing for a
particular instrument or a viola?
>> Brett Dean: A particular
make of instrument?
Yeah, well, that-- that's something
that I haven't necessarily done
that much of, except of course--
and this is then going into
very much the time of today--
writing a piece for electric violin
and a very particular
sort of electric violin.
I've had six strings and had a
very particular pick up piece
that in fact includes a
moment where the soloist--
it was written for the great
Australian violinist Richard
Tognetti who is the
artistic director
of the Australian Chamber Orchestra.
And at one point he just
blows across the strings,
which not every electric
violin can do and so
that was very custom-built.
Also, all the effects
were custom-built
around improvising
together with Richard
on the material used for the piece.
So, that was-- that was
a case in point, yeah.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford: OK.
And getting back to
sound, perhaps we could end
with a new sound you've discovered
or something you're hearing.
>> Brett Dean: Well, I mean
there's one moment in my piece
which has a lot of what
I call angled tremolo
or brush tremolo, which is--
[ Music ]
Which of course isn't what a
Stradivari viola was built for--
not in 1690, but it-- I kind of
like, you know, the fact that,
you know, to-- the chance
to get some different
and extended techniques and
try them out on a 1690 Strad.
It's kind of cool.
You know? It keeps it alive, too.
Yeah, it has a wonderful
sweetness too up here.
[ Music ]
It's just a very--
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
It really does.
Could you play that a little more?
That was very-- really was sweet.
[ Music ]
>> Brett Dean: Yeah.
I mean it's just a beautiful,
beautiful thing to play on.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Well, thank you very much.
>> Brett Dean: My pleasure.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
I'm looking forward
to hearing your commission.
>> Brett Dean: Well-- and thank you
to the library for this wonderful--
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
And to the Tuscan Corporation.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah, indeed.
It's a joy.
>> Carol Lynn Ward-Bamford:
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.